The tech guys are going to read your fucking mine.
Yeah,
you,
you shouldn't buy it because they don't update them very well by devices.
I mean,
why?
So?
Yeah,
I'm sure.
I mean,
okay.
I talk about something and I don't type it in.
I don't write a message.
I don't write an email and I'll see an ad.
So it's fine on us all the time.
That doesn't happen to you.
I,
it hasn't happened to me,
but it's happened to enough people that I believe you.
It's insane.
I believe.
You know what?
No matter what really crazy talk to so many people that have had that happen.
Somebody sent me a tweet yesterday that said they were listening to a podcast
that we were doing.
We were talking about something and then that something appeared in their Google
ads and he's like,
I never looked up this.
I never,
and oh no.
It wasn't a Google ad.
It was a youtube search.
It was a youtube suggested.
He's like my fucking computers listening.
Yup.
Don Pewter.
And what APP is doing this?
I mean I'm about to just go to a flip phone because I don't want to,
it's,
it's bullshit.
We know that youtube audio is being listened to because they're mining it to for
ad ad stuff already.
It's not even real.
It's not a spy thing that's out there.
That's how they do it.
Right,
but is that if you're playing things?
Yeah,
so when we're playing,
so if he's playing a podcast on Youtube,
youtube listening to that and that's how they suggest it's just happening in
ads.
What I think might be happening with people are noticing now is not just that
it's happening within the software.
It's that your actual device,
the microphone is on and the Laptop camera is on.
So people will block the camera with tape.
They're not blocking the microphone.
Exactly.
How the hell do you block the microphone?
You don't even know where it is.
How do I,
could we have like some sort of tutorial about like how we can prevent all of
our shit from being collected?
Like that whole,
the Facebook,
Cambridge Analytica thing.
I feel like everyone missed the boat of what that story was.
You heard about that,
right?
The Cambridge Analytica,
they're data mining all your shit.
It's like,
yeah,
if you're on Facebook,
everything's being taken in data mind that's very obvious.
But what wasn't really investigated,
I think channel four did this crazy investigation where they pretended like they
were a patron trying to hire Cambridge Analytica is and billionaire dude and
they put them on camera.
It's all recorded.
The guys are basically like,
it's basically like a private intelligence from almost like a black water where
you can hire mercenaries to set up honeypots with prostitutes.
Takedown politicians would spy on them.
They set up shell companies with the mic six Massaad.
Um,
it's all just untraceable shit.
They just ghost out.
They said they can ghost in out of countries.
They literally said that they stage the entire Kenyan election.
They were like,
we staged the whole thing.
We wrote all the speeches.
Yeah.
Ken is gentleman.
This is,
this is backed by billionaire Robert Mercer.
The same guy who can behind channel four did a crazy investigation about it and
the,
and so that's why I'm just like,
why is everyone focusing on Facebook data?
This is like a crazy
stupid game that people play with is called flat farmland,
Farmville or something world farm.
Fuck.
What is that shit?
That was the thing,
Farmville.
Yeah,
that,
that's what people were talking about.
Oh,
you're going to have data
here like changing the government.
They're killing people and like the,
and Knights and the Breitbart people are,
how many other companies are there like this?
I always think,
yeah.
While we're all focused on Russian trolls,
14 Russian trolls in St Petersburg.
How many companies like Cambridge Analytica,
like blackwater?
Like all these things are operating around the world doing all this gotta be a
fuck load a lot.
There's gotta be a lot that we don't know of because it's only when something
fucks up or someone gets shot in the head and like,
yeah.
They're like,
well,
what is that?
Oh,
change the Kenyan elections.
Cool.
Like in,
we never heard of this.
People are talking about it.
There's got to be so many of those things that are just bubbling up in the
distance.
Disturbing men.
Disturbing.